hear you brother I gotta set you free  okay you got seven minutes stay focused  the art in here is worth millions  proceed to step two  it won't open sorry man you're on your  own  foreign  [Music]  number three  number three come in  help me get me out of here  [Music]  God  [Music]  got a Tonkin Square Park  do that for me  [Applause]  nobody here but us pictures  [Music]  I feel you brother I understand  it's free  when I was a kid My teacher asked me  what I would say from my house if it  were on fire  I answered my Sketchbook my AC DC albums  and my crowd show I didn't mention my  parents or my sister  does that make me a bad person  cats died  music face  but art  is for Keeps  [Music]